te c'est la grande série de france 2
quel lundi 16 novembre et mardi
mi-novembre les deux premiers épisodes
voilà alors très réussi catherine est ce
que est ce que je faisais là ça serait
bien qu'il vienne quand même ouais
est-ce que josep sunyer josé
bonsoir bonsoir alors je sais ce que
vous avez le trac pour lundi soir là oui
bien sûr ouais monsieur là vous voulez
vous millions de téléspectateurs ouais
j'aimerais mais quand on prend trois
depardieu par exemple on a un prix non
alors vous les aimez bien parce que
guillaume a dit en parlant de boue josé
il a dit je lui doit plusieurs
résurrection c'est vrai ça c'est lui qui
l'a dit en tout cas moi je lui dois
beaucoup de plaisir quoi parce que on
est revenu au travail
et bien voilà c'est vraiment un acteur
que j'adore et c'est formidable de
tourner avec les et alors vous julie san
jose et vous n'auriez peut-être jamais
été actrice assez dans les liens du
coeur va les faire fuir
ces deux deniers du culte ouais elle m'a
fait dire cette phrase implacable oui
disait à tchéky karyo avec un air
pénétré attends tu as volé il denier du
culte oui j'ai digéré jamais franchement
j'avais ma vocation j'étais en est une
machin et elle m'a dit écoute ça va tu
le fais j'ai dit ok je vais je vais
taper décevant tant pis ils trouvent ça
m'a beaucoup amusé l'alternance elle a
donc cessé de la forêt lui doit beaucoup
et oui j'avais une voix des personnages
magnifiques se [ __ ] une reconnaissance
elle sait on en a tous regardent la
branche interconnecté arrêté parce que
c'est moi vraiment qui suis tellement
heureuse d'avoir le le plaisir de
c'est vraiment
voilà déjà un bon jose en tous les cas
merci on vous dit merde pour lundi soir
on sera tous devant le poste merci jeu
des yeux
guillaume vous sembler un peu plus
proche maintenant tous les deux non oui
moi je me l'étais très loin on s'est
beaucoup engagé comme tout le monde mais
avant que vous étiez un petit peu fermé
quand même devant les appels au secours
de votre frère non jeter l'armé bon vous
tombiez fatigant ouais ouais mais je
vous rassure il était maintenant
beaucoup moins il est paisible bien sûr
ouais ouais je suis peut-être même plus
fatigant de celui du coup mais dans la
famille faisait du mal à communiquer
quand même temps par sms
sinon y'a quoi il ya l'alcool ou la
psychanalyse beaucoup moins c'est vrai
en plus la psychanalyse ça vous a aidé
beaucoup moins il est extraordinaire
parce qu'il dit moi ma mère était dans
la psy tous montés dans l'accident quand
je suis arrivé la première fois chez le
psychanalyste je lui ai tout dit en une
séance
et puis finalement le mec m'a regardé on
n'avait plus rien à se dire et c'est là
que ça a commencé vraiment en fait
joe comment oui il m'a dit d'apprendre à
apprendre à sion j'avais jamais pensé à
ça ouais c'est bien mais aujourd'hui
alors j'apprends oui c'est vrai je pense
alors ils s'embrassaient c'est tout seul
devant mon ça me ferait du bien le foyer
des jeunes merci quels sont maintenant
est maintenant je fais de l'humour aura
pas le livrer la venue de s'allonger de
payer 90
l'alcool c'est fini alors moi bon bah
moi je vois plus mes voyages confirme
voire bah ouais normalement quoi bien
sûr le lui soumettait minable et nebojsa
y arriver j'en témoigne jean bouin et
quand votre père dit à la télé
britannique qui boit kata cette
bouteille de vin par jour c'est parce
que ça c'est quand il vend son vin c'est
pas possible de voir cette bouteille de
vin par jour quand même s'il l'a fait
peut-être ya 40 ans ouais il à faire il
jean carmet à l'époque je pense pas mais
les gens pas vu l'émission son camarade
angleterre en plus l'ouest attirent un
quinze jours quand il a dit qu'il
arrêtait le cinéma ça je trouve ça très
vite vous croyez que c'est vrai ça oui
ça fait déjà 10 ans qu'il nous dit donc
un moment quand on a fait 170 films dont
quelques chefs-d'oeuvre dont quelques
navets peut-être cela
en tous les cas tous les deux il ya une
chose qui vous réunit maintenant
désormais c'est là c'est la musique
vous vous êtes mis à chanter là il lui
sortait chez naïve un stabat mater écrit
par par couler par bruno coulais qui a
fait la musique du film d'ailleurs les
rois maudits gendre et bruno en fait sur
la sur scène je viens et dans la vie
tout contrat ce moment même on voir là
encore quand ça ça va sortir le 27
novembre
c'est à battre matt hunwick c'est
magnifique
sur scène connaît
j'étais pas mal ton duo avec juliette
déjà mais je chante on est samedi ce
soir je chante ce soir à l'olympia avec
juliette bâton magique
moi j'y viens avec moi pour me le dire
je vois que c'est ça qui est formidable
en direct c'est guillaume n'a pas remis
et en même temps ici oui c'est bien
comme un enjeu envie de faire de la
scène
oui ça y est vous avez enfin admis que
c'était votre truc qua non ah ouais mais
souvent ce qui nous fascine le plus
on le contourne le contrôle jusqu'à
temps que vous
ouais mais ça y est là moi je vous dis
chasseurs ça fait 32 ans que je le
connais je le connais ouais non parce
qu'on on connaissait sa famille il m'a
surprise en nous non on choisit pas ses
parents venant sa famille vraiment puis
j'ai choisi je pense à savoir 6 à 8 ans
c'est beau c'est beau une famille
réconcilier alors vous donc bien
évidemment vous lisiez avec le
violoniste laurent korcia qui a mis le
pied à l'étrier pour le stabat mater un
voilà et gilles vous faites aussi
volontiers de la scène pour le concert
pour ingrid betancourt vous êtes monté
sur scène avec la mer pour fusionner
c'est quoi si je jouais pas très bien je
verrai mon coeur yens la voix est
faiblarde
donc conclusion vous habitez tous les
deux à bougival près d'un glauque tout
va bien ça y est quoi enfin elle est
revenue sur bougival
ouais mais on se croise des fois il se
passe rien
comment vous les trouvez j'aime les deux
2 à malley trop bien si tu préfères
quelques mois j'avais préfère gêner un
mois par région à l'autre
alors vous gêne ce plan sentimental vous
êtes super sereine j'aime quelqu'un
depuis 18 ans je sais qu'il m'aime
nous voyons peut-être quatre ou cinq
fois par an c'est magnifique voilà non
mais c'est bien en arriver là
4 5 fois par an c'est pas un peu
redondant c'est vrai cette histoire un
jeune avait 4 5 fois par an et voilà
oui la comète de halley ce mec là c'est
qu'ils ne savaient pas un autre pour la
terre va trouver c'est pas un livreur 4
c'est quelqu'un qui a un métier créatif
quelqu'un jana qui est un métier créatif
dit autrefois la passion me prenait
beaucoup de temps désormais s'exerce
autrement donc elle s'exerce comment la
passion aujourd'hui elle s'exerce à
travers la création un travail travers
la relation avec les autres l'obsession
du monde du cinéma qui est un moyen de
montrer le monde de toucher le monde
non c'est là que s'exerce la passion
désormais voilà ouais mais ça se prépare
trouve quatre cinq fois par an avec
alors ça c'est un trush et autre chose
mais bon on n'en parle pas cette
émission cette émission est célèbre pour
sa discrétion richard n'a jamais fait
chier personne avec la vie bref voilà et
et je pense qu'on va pas commencer ce
soir sans toutefois jeter un peu
ridicule franchement alors guillaume
j'ai vu que j'ai signé l'appel des 200
dans le nouvel observateur sur la honte
que représentent les prisons françaises
alors vous avez été en prison à 17 ans 1
ouais vous étiez six personnes pour 9
mètres carrés vous dites oui aller deux
fois il ya tourné en 1
je parle que de la première fois là ça
va venir bonnart non c'est pas ça non
c'est parce que non parce que vous
expliquer la réalité mais ces bonnes
c'est grave et sérieux quoi on me dit si
on se rebelle pas on se fait marcher
dessus est pour le moins on devient une
serpillière dit vous ennuie un objet
sexuel et vous vous dites le premier qui
m'a fait chier je vais éclater la tête
et je me suis retrouvé au mitard quoi
cirque ont fait il n'y a pas 36
solutions quoi n'y a pas 36 solutions il
faut avoir de l'argent enfin c'est
vraiment tout c'est un système qui est
un crabe est ce l'homme
vraiment c'est la femme je sais encore
pu reconstruire
c'est le type de la prison nous on
allait au parloir découvert on dit c'est
comme ça genre ville et il était sourire
et elle seule qui y vivaient pas ça
comme un psychodrame
alors tous les autres qui tirait ligue 1
tout était complet quoi il n'était pas
du tout un bon d'en faire plus jeunes il
se plaignait pas sur lui et sûrement
mais était prêt mais je veux dire c'est
vraiment l'école du crime et est en tout
cas c'est on traite vraiment les gens
comme de la merde quoi y en a d'autres
moi ça rend les gens
et l'année moi sinon je vais signaler
quand même que le 21 novembre sortie du
coffret jeanne moreau succès confidences
lors ya un cd best of avec 27 titres
dont celui là 1
il ya un dvd je veux premier dvd avec
des scopitone des chansons extraites de
vos films et un livret de 16 pages
alors puisqu'on est à vendre des disques
je veux aussi vous montrer la bande
originale des rois maudits
les rois maudits l'a dit sur france 2 et
mardi encore ce pont de vaux voilà